Уже почти две недели склады нашей компании подвергаются террористическим атакам.
Почему именно наши склады?
Вайлберрис – народный маркетплейс, которым пользуется каждый житель нашей страны и других стран тоже.
Поэтому удары по нам – это удары по сотням миллионов людей в десяти странах одновременно.
Нашим сотрудникам, нашим продавцам, производителям, логистам, владельцам ПВЗ,
тысячам других предпринимателей, исполнителям и покупателям, среди которых есть и социально незащищенные люди.
Атаки на инфраструктуру Вайлберрис – это атаки на мирных людей.
И повторюсь, не только россиян.
В нашей экосистеме ведут бизнес десятки тысяч людей из Кыргызстана, Белоруссии, Казахстана, Армении, Узбекистана и Китая.
Предприниматели этих стран тоже понесли миллиардные убытки.
Я вижу в интернете рассуждения диванных экономиков.
И экспертов на тему защиты наших объектов, противовоздушной обороны и так далее.
Повторю, наши склады оборудованы всеми доступными средствами защиты.
С первого дня атак мы ежедневно усиливаем и укрепляем линию обороны,
используя в том числе и инженерные решения.
По понятным причинам детали раскрывать я не буду.
Но будьте уверены, мы каждый день модернизируем системы защиты.
И тот факт, что мы успешно отражаем большую часть
атак тому прямое подтверждение.
Это при том, что террористы каждый день усиливают огневую мощь.
Например, только на склад в Екатеринбурге, где загорелись машины на парковке,
летело более 200 БПЛА самолетного типа.
Теперь хотела бы рассказать о противопожарной защите наших объектов.
С 2024 года, когда мы создали объединенную компанию,
мы полностью перестроили работу наших складов по противопожарной безопасности.
За эти два года мы организовали собственные противопожарные бригады,
оборудовали все объекты с самыми современными системами пожаротушения,
производим собственные комплектующие и регулярно проводим эвакуационные учения с персоналом.
Около 2000 человек ежедневно обеспечивают противопожарную безопасность на всех наших складах.
Возглавляет службу пожарной безопасности полковник внутренней службы,
бывший сотрудник МЧС со стажем более 26 лет,
который в последнее время был в состоянии возникнуть в течение всего года.
Это позволило и позволяет нам обеспечить безопасность людей на складах,
оперативно локализовывать возгорания и по возможности сохранять в целостности товары наших продавцов.
При этом надо понимать, что БПЛА, которые бьют по промышленным объектам,
нефтеперерабатывающим заводам или складам маркетплейсов,
несут поражающие элементы, чтобы пострадало как можно больше людей.
Террористические атаки на наши склады являются обстоятельствами,
непреодолимой силой.
Внесение или невнесение этого пункта в оферты не имеет значения,
поэтому эти потери по закону не подлежат возмещению.
К сожалению, на просторах интернета появилось много мошенников и юристов,
которые хотят нажиться на наши с вами общие беде,
пользуются ситуацией и незнанием людей, предлагают свои услуги для решения проблем.
Поэтому я обращаюсь ко всем нашим продавцам.
Уважаемые партнеры!
Смотрите только официальным каналам коммуникаций нашей компании и государству.
В текущей ситуации помочь вам можем только мы и государство.
Рассказываю, какие меры мы предпринимаем сейчас.
Мы выступили как проводник интересов малого и среднего бизнеса
и уже обсудили с правительством страны комплексные меры поддержки всем пострадавшим предпринимателям.
В настоящее время разрабатывается общая система,
по которой помощь получит каждый.
В ближайшие дни набор этих мер будет озвучен.
Пока система разрабатывается, мы провели уже два транша поддерживающих выплат продавцам,
чьи товары пострадали в результате атак.
Во вторую волну попало почти 100 тысяч представителей малого и среднего бизнеса,
многие из которых уже получили начисления.
Для наших более крупных партнеров мы ввели повышенную скидку постоянного покупателя на их товар за наш счет,
кредитные каникулы в нашем банке,
и ряд иных мер поддержки.
Со следующей недели мы планируем проводить очные встречи с предпринимателями в наиболее пострадавших регионах,
чтобы точечно решать их актуальные проблемы, появившиеся на фоне ситуации.
Я уже говорила, что мы сейчас максимально оперативно перестраиваем свою логистическую инфраструктуру,
распределяем потоки по различным логистическим объектам,
чтобы сохранить скорость доставки и оборачиваемость товаров наших партнеров.
В целях безопасности детали раскрыть не могу, но будьте уверены, мы делаем все возможное для этого.
Никогда вас не подводили и всегда находили решение любой проблемы,
и я не вижу причин, почему текущая ситуация должна стать исключением.
У нас десятки предложений по аренде логистических мощностей на территории России и за ее пределами.
Часть договоров уже заключена.
Помимо этого, скоро мы запустим в эксплуатацию наши объекты,
которые строили в других странах нашего присутствия.
Совершая удары по нам, террористы прикрывают истинные причины и обвиняют нас в том,
что мы якобы продаем товары военного назначения.
Но вы можете открыть любой мировой маркетплейс Amazon или Alibaba и посмотреть, есть ли у нас то, чего нет у них.
Никакой логики и здравого смысла, рациональности в действиях террористов нет и не может быть.
Противник сам сделал публичное заявление о том,
что атаки на Wildberries направлены на обычных граждан.
Единственная их цель – оказать давление, дестабилизировать, вызвать панику и шок у большого количества людей.
Единственное, что можно сейчас сделать, это с холодной головой всем нам, предпринимательскому сообществу России,
иметь план пересборки на ближайшее время, адаптироваться и трансформироваться.
Мы, предприниматели, умеем это делать, как никто другой.
Мы видим, что ситуация сплотила всех.
И предприниматели, и покупатели, и бизнес-сообщества, и представители региональных властей объединяются, чтобы вместе решить проблему.
Мы сделаем все, чтобы помочь бизнесу справиться с этой непростой ситуацией.
Я благодарю всех за поддержку.
Вместе мы сильнее.
Потому что Wildberries – это и есть вы.